depuis le 6 novembre dernier à 15h36
les françaises travaillent gratuitement
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
ce sujet de société de démocratie
intéresse à plus d'un titre
la préfète que je suis mais je ne vais
pas vous parler de ça ce soir
dans ce soir je vais vous parler de
confiance cette confiance qui m'a manqué
pendant plusieurs années mais qui me
fait me présenter devant vous ce soir
cette confiance qui ne se décrète pas
mais se construit dans notre relation à
l'autre dans nos vécus heureux ou
malheureux dans notre capacité à voir le
verre toujours à moitié plein et mon
message ce soit est assez simple il vous
dit d'oser poser la confiance en vous
alors si le message est simple
l'histoire est plus sinueuse et je vous
rassure elle ne se développe pas avec le
sens du vent non elle chemine au gré des
rencontres que nous faisons des
expériences que nous vivons et des coups
de chance que nous saisissons je veux
vous en relater 3 la rencontre d'abord
avec mon institutrice de ces grandes
dames rigoureuse et souriante du mois
c'est l'idée que je m'en fais
aujourd'hui quand je me remémore cette
année scolaire
le premier mot qui me vient à l'esprit
c'est douceur montpak madame cayuela
c'est son nom malgré lui non pas qu'elle
ait été laxiste au contraire elle été
bienveillante et c'est dans cette
atmosphère de bienveillance
que la confiance a commencé à prendre
forme
puis vers l'adolescence collège
le déménagement du hlm de banlieue oui
c'est comme ça que les parents
appelaient l'appartement des yvelines
qui faisait mon bonheur déménagement
donc du hlm de banlieue
direction la réunion alors oui je sais
ce soir sa maman novembre et malgré une
météo clémente la réunion c'est une
destination qui peut faire rêver et pour
l'ado que j'étais qu'elle est aussi les
matches et qu'ils pouvaient accéder à
paris en train en moins d'une heure qui
fréquentaient les mêmes amis depuis la
maternelle
la réunion c'était très bien pour les
vacances c'est un cauchemar pour l'aide
et le cauchemar a pris forme
car pour l'abonné les mathématiques que
gt5 sur 20 a été la première note que
m'a attribué le professeur de maths sous
ses sarcasmes
à mon arrivée à la réunion comment faire
alors pour lui démontrer qu'il se
trompait et que je n'étais pas une
usurpatrice et bien j'ai rempli pendant
les vacances de l'été austral un cahier
196 pages petit format petit caron
l'exercice de maths et finalement ça a
payé quelques années plus tard j'ai
obtenu un bac c avec une mention la
confiance n'est pas revenue pour autant
parce que les deux années suivantes en
classes préparatoires étaient plus de
passer sous le signe de la crainte de
l'échec et du dénigrement
alors la confiance effectivement s'est
endormi durablement
et là encore ma volonté de ne pas passer
pour une usurpatrice m'a permis de ne
pas sombrer
quelques années plus tard quand j'ai
découvrirez cette magnifique citation du
tennisman arthur ashe
une des clés du succès c'est la
confiance en soi une des clés de la
confiance un soir c'est la préparation
je me souviens vaguement cahier
d'exercices et de mes fiches de cours en
classe de prépa
car la confiance ça n'est ni de la
naïveté ni de l'outrecuidance c'est
plutôt je crois un mélange équilibré
entre humilité cultivé et audace
travailler c'est le fruit des rencontres
que nous faisons je vous ai parlé
madame qu'elle l'a aidé ma rencontre
avec elle c'est la synthèse des
expériences que nous vivons je vous
parlerai de l'expérience de l'ajesaia et
c'est la somme des moments de chances
que nous saisissons je vous parlerai de
chance aussi pour avoir confiance en toi
vous dire il faut connaître ses limites
et oui il vient pour connaître ses
limites comme quand nous étions enfants
à que nous sommes rapprochés un peu trop
près du feu il faut aller à leur
recherche
l'ajesaia jeune chambre internationale a
été pour moi le lieu de cette recherche
d'ailleurs depuis j'appelle la jeune
chambre l'espace de tous les possibles
ma mère à peine la jeune chambre la
secte les dents ça c'est une autre
histoire
nous sommes en 1996 c'est ma première
expérience avec la jeune chambre
internationale mouvements pour la
formation des jeunes à la prise de
responsabilité pour des changements
positifs qu'elle accroche
comment ne pas être séduit j'ai été
séduite avec quelques amis nous sommes
en 1997 nous avons un projet 2005 la
réunion île bio l'idée est ambitieuse
mais elle est assez simple en 2005 où
seront confrontés à des contraintes
environnementales fortes si nous nous y
prenons bittan à l'avant nous pouvons
transformer ces contrats en des atouts
pour le développement de notre île
nous développons notre méthodologie de
projet nous sensibilisons de grand
public qui nous suit et puis et puis
rien
les décideurs n'adhère pas
la preuve est que nous sommes
aujourd'hui en 2018 et si j'évoque
devant vous la réunion sans doute
penserez-vous à l'intense grand raid
volcan sans nous pas une bio pourtant
cette expérience a été un succès à bien
des égards elle nous a appris à jean
pascal
frédéric hervé marco et moi de quoi nous
étions capables nous étions capables de
produire un disque cette expérience a
inspiré le groupe de musique jusqu'à
quand j'ai écrit deux chansons pour
notre projet la réunion nous étions
capables de monter une émission de
télévision
nous avons réalisé une émission de
télévision dans laquelle nous remettons
des prix un certain nombre d'acteurs du
développement durable à la réunion
dans les années dans la fin des années
90 nous étions capables aussi et surtout
d'inspirer un certain nombre de
personnes
j'étais d'ailleurs à la réunion la
semaine dernière pour les vacances de la
toussaint
je peux vous dire que
les associations de protection de
l'environnement les agriculteurs bio les
professionnels du recyclage ont tous en
mémoire notre action et disent tous
encore aujourd'hui leur fierté d'y avoir
participé
quelle meilleure chose pour cultiver la
confiance en soi que le témoignage
positif d'autrui mais encore faut-il
saisir ces messages positifs y être
attentif
les accepter certains appellent ça
l'optimisme je pense assez pour
l'espérance de césaire l'espérance
d'aimé césaire une espérance conquise
lucide hors de toute naïveté
je suis déléguée régionale aux droits
des femmes et à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes à la réunion depuis
un peu plus de trois ans j'ai besoin de
changement
lydie err un ami un jour m'appelle doit
être au mois de mer lundi aux alentours
de 8 heures je suis à mon bureau à l'eau
sophie c'est didier regarde le journal
ni un poste pour toi nous jettent sur
les pages emploi du quotidien qui s'est
déposé sur mon bureau cherche cherche
pas de poste qui correspond à ce que
j'attendais
j'appelle didier non regarde dans
l'édito me dit il je lis attentivement
l'éditorial le rédacteur en chef du
quotidien
ironise sur le gouvernement de l'époque
qui n'a pas nommés ministres réunionnais
et qui peine visiblement à trouver un
délégué interministériel pour l'égalité
des chances des français d outre-mer
je pense que mon ami plaisante
il insista sur sophie ce poste est pour
toi cette délégation c'est toi je lui
fais confiance
je commence à me documenter sur le post
sur les attendus sur les titulaires
précédents
l'idée fait son chemin la confiance
gagne du terrain
elle est alimentée par les informations
que je recueille l'idée devient une des
fixes à tel point d'ailleurs que quand
j'ai cru que le poste allait l'échappée
vers un mieux ciel et terre j'ai demandé
à mon ami journaliste de relire ma
lettre de motivation et mon cv
j'ai mobilisé tous les soutiens mon
supérieur hiérarchique du moment la
député de ma circonscription j'ai même
appelé un ancien chef dont le nom de
famille était le même que celui de la
personne qui était chargée du
recrutement
tout ça parce que j'étais convaincu mon
pad être la personne la plus compétente
mais d'être la bonne personne au bon
moment pourquoi les deux délégués
précédents étaient des hommes suis une
femme les deux délégués précédent était
antillais je suis originaire de la
réunion
moi j'appelle ça de la chance et ma
détermination a été concluante en
octobre 2012 j'ai été nommé à la tête de
cette délégation
je suis resté trois ans trois ans durant
lesquels je n'ai jamais oublié de
remercier la bonne étoile et je fais
encore actuellement parce que ce poste a
été pour moi un véritable tremplin
c'est lui qui m'a conduite dans le nord
puis il ya kelly a presque un an
ici dans le territoire de belfort et ce
soir
devant vous à belfort
alors je les dis mon message est simple
la confiance
si la sphère de rencontre celle affaire
d'expérience c'est la sphère de chance
ce poste bien sûr a été un tremplin et
c'est ce poste et les rencontres que
j'ai pu faire
madame cayeux et là par hasard vous
m'entendez vraiment je veux vous
remercier d'avoir cru en moi et l'avoir
écrit c'est ce poste et les expériences
que j'ai vécues heureuses ou
malheureuses mais toujours riche
d'enseignements grâce à la jeune chambre
internationale
ce poste est évidemment la chance que
j'ai su saisir quand elle passait parce
que je les ai reconnus alors des
rencontres vous en avez fait et vous en
ferez encore tout au long de votre vie
de nombreuses rues des expériences vous
en avez vécu et vous en vivres et encore
beaucoup d expérience extrêmement variés
alors ouvrez l'oeil affûté vos oreilles
sortez les antennes et guetter la chance
pour la saisir une fois que vous l'aurez
saisi de la lâcher par et osez osez la
confiance aux et la confiance en vous
donc vous mesdames là quelques-unes dans
la salle pour vous mesdames enfin pour
nous mais d'arbres
cette confiance en soi c'est aussi un
moyen de réduire l'écart qu'il ya encore
aujourd'hui existe entre les salaires
des femmes et les salaires des hommes